vamos a hablar ahora de economía quién
france24 está conmigo en el estudio
daniela blandón daniela muy buenas
noches este jueves entró en vigencia en
mexico una nueva ley de etiquetado de
alimentos de qué se trata si santiago
muy buenas noches primero vamos a
empezar con el siguiente dato méxico es
el segundo país con más sobrepeso en el
mundo esto afecta a siete de cada diez
adultos y tres de cada diez niños para
disminuir el consumo de la llamada
comida chatarra los vendedores ahora
están obligados a poner un rótulo
frontal en los productos
industrializados y bebidas azucaradas la
idea a santiago es que se advierta sobre
estos valores nutricionales el símbolo
en cada empaque debe decir alto en
seguido de lo que se quiera destacar por
ejemplo grasas saturadas sodio azúcares
entre otras este modelo que ya se aplica
en chile- supuso una victoria para los
especialistas en salud y defensores del
consumidor sin embargo también un
aumento de tensión entre el gobierno y
la industria hablemos ahora de la
atención que también hay entre la unión
europea
no unido porque bruselas empezó ya con
unas acciones legales contra londres por
el acuerdo del brics y específicamente
de santiago abrió un proceso que se
puede derivar incluso en multas por
parte del tribunal superior de la unión
europea por eso puede tomar varios años
el conflicto es por la llamada ley de
mercado interno que cursó en el
parlamento británico esta iniciativa le
permitiría al reino unido- saltarse
algunas normas pactadas dentro del
acuerdo de divorcio el 'break' si te dio
un paso hacia este diciembre para
negociar un acuerdo comercial ahora
mismo están conversando en bruselas y a
mediados de este mes habrá una cumbre en
europa pero en vez de avances lo que hay
es más tensiones escuchemos
habíamos invitado a nuestros amigos
británicos a eliminar las partes
problemáticas de su proyecto de ley del
mercado interior a final de septiembre
bailando september en la pcia straight
el plazo venció ayer y las disposiciones
problemáticas no se han eliminado por lo
que la comisión decidió enviar una carta
de notificación formal al gobierno del
reina miento este es el primer paso en
un procedimiento de infracción de sexto
es estar en anal frenchman costilla
danielle hablemos ahora del salario
mínimo en venezuela cae a valores
históricos esto es impresionante si
santiago mire la moneda local en
venezuela ha perdido casi un 90% de su
valor frente al dólar durante la
pandemia hace un año el sueldo que
reciben al menos 4 millones de
trabajadores y una cantidad similar de
pensionados era de 2 dólares mensuales
pero hoy este 92 centavos según un
análisis de la agencia efe esto si se
tiene en cuenta a santiago que para
comprar un dólar hoy se necesitan 430
mil 670 bolívares y el salario mínimo es
de 400 mil bolívares o sea menos de un
dólar con eso alcanza para comprar un
kilo de harina de maíz
esta cifra también es 40 veces menos de
los 125 dólares con los que vive una
persona que está en condición de miseria
según naciones unidas el gobierno de
nicolás maduro ha dicho que la situación
obedece a la presión económica de eeuu y
esto ha llevado a que la economía esté
parcialmente dolarizada de manera
virtual hablemos ahora de la empresa
sueca h&m que la descubrieron que está
espiando a los empleados como le parece
santiago pues esto le valió a la
multinacional de ropa una multa de 41
millones de dólares por parte de la
comisión de protección de datos de
hamburgo en alemania la investigación
encontró que la empresa sueca recopiló
información de algunos de sus empleados
que van desde detalles inofensivos hasta
problemas familiares y creencias
religiosas a esta información podían
acceder unos 50 gerentes y se usaba para
tomar decisiones sobre estos
colaboradores la entidad dijo que esto
era una usurpación de los derechos
civiles por su parte la empresa asumió
toda responsabilidad y pidió disculpas a
santiago
indicadores rápidas o street encierro
positivo el mercado está muy pendiente
de las negociaciones sobre un nuevo
paquete de estímulo en europa también
están a la espera de lo mismo pero con
la atención sobre el break sheet y en
américa latina' grandes movimientos
argentinas se disparó y méxico cayó
cifra del día para el cierre muy a
propósito del día internacional del café
se le va a gustar 168 39 millones de
sacos es el consumo mundial proyectado
por la organización internacional del
café para la cosecha 2019 2020 me tomo
tres cafés al día daniela muchas gracias
por esta información es toda la economía
en france 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]